how are you both doing today doing good
uh we love that Iron Man in the back you
know we got something I see Jack
Skeleton Jack Skellington we see some
there's some X-Men back there what's
back there there's a whole bunch of
stuff it's to distract you from this and
it works every time
um all kidding aside I really want to
say congrats on the movie
um I am very happy it was made I really
appreciate when people point out the
hypocrisy of certain religious leaders
and um I'm just gonna say thank you
thank you I I am curious though do you
think when you were growing up if your
parents had allowed you to read Harry
Potter and go trick-or-treating and do
things I was reading the Press notes do
you think this movie would have been
made so our parents did allow us to do
that but we it it's it's part of part of
why I think this dichotomy exists within
us because our parents although we did
go to church every Sunday
um they they did encourage critical
thinking in us and they encouraged they
did encourage us to ask questions and
um they also love Halloween and Harry
Potter so they weren't gonna deprive us
of that but I think despite that the
messaging that we were getting from the
church in and of itself and other people
within the community was that they these
things are bad that they think these
things are evil and we shouldn't be
doing it
um so this was gonna be this was gonna
happen either way I think yeah yeah I'm
gonna ask you now the most important
question of um of of the entire day I
think uh what was it like for the two of
you doing the Harry Potter tour in
London
oh it was perfect I mean it was a lot of
what we just did just like yeah it was
it was a lot of shock and awe I think
we're we're big fan girls Harry Potter
fan girls and so that and I think
having you know being filmmakers now and
having made film seeing how all those
things truly came together in a
filmmaking way was just like it was the
ultimate yes it was amazing and our
parents were there and our parents were
there with us
I hate asking a generic thing but what
was it about this material that said we
have to tell this story uh yeah I mean I
think it's because it was like
for lack of a better term plaguing us at
a particular time in our lives where we
were uh you know struggling with not
driving with a lot of what organized
religions seem to be about and what it
had to offer but then also still very
much feeling a connection to uh Southern
Baptist culture and our own personal
spirituality and trying to figure out
why it is that their wife felt like
there was such a split
um and so I think that that was like
really what the core of it was was that
we were from this culture
um and there was a lot that we loved
about it but there was a lot that we had
critique about yeah you guys ended up
filming on the side of a road uh for
part of the movie and it felt obviously
like you can't lock down an entire road
so there are people you know driving by
that are you know oblivious to maybe
that you're filming a movie what was it
actually like having them on the side of
the road and the praise miming and
everything that went on there it was I
mean we locked down the sidewalk I think
or at least some of them on the sidewalk
but definitely not the sidewalk is right
by the road
um so people would stop you know and I I
think a lot of people were like wait
what are what are they doing doing I
think the black Jesus statue also got a
lot of attention they were like what is
this but I think when people recognize
that it was Regina and Sterling on the
side of the road people that didn't
really stop their cars yeah and would
talk to us in the middle we were like we
have to work but they were very much you
know uh
intrigued by what was going on their
performance is obviously they're
everything for the movie if you don't
buy into what they're selling forget it
but they're both they're both incredible
in the movie can you sort of talk about
how you worked with them to get them
ready to step on set what did you want
them to know and you know the way to
portray their characters
uh specificity about these this culture
and these characters they already knew
they were both raised uh very similarly
to how we were raised
um definitely raised in the church and
um you know Regina's from Georgia and
Sterling is from San Luis um and so
there there was a lot of shorthand there
already yeah
um but as far as developing their actual
characters a lot of it was like talking
about the stuff that isn't on isn't on
screen like talking about backstory
talking about why don't uh Trinity and
Lee Curtis have kids
um talking about what
um how they met how they met like um
when did Regina's dad actually pass away
like it's like all of these things that
aren't necessarily informing the story
that's on screen but it informs their
characters I'm fascinated by the editing
process because that's where it all
comes together yeah can you can you sort
of talk about what it was like in the
editing room trying to find the right
tone that you were looking for and just
maybe how talk a little bit about the
challenge
I mean I think I think we just we took
our time finding the right editor I
think like you said everything comes to
either come together or falls apart in
the editing room
um and so for us it was very important
to find an editor who has worked with a
complexity of tones and we also really
wanted someone who has worked in both
Real documentary and uh you know
standard cinematic narrative film uh
film storytelling and so that process I
think because we took our time finding
the right editor we all just meshed
really really well yeah
um and it was it was honestly pretty
seamless obviously they were you know
they're always tough points tough courts
that you know keep us up late at night
but it was pretty oh
what's going on somebody's here
[Laughter]
that's that's how that's exactly what
set was like exactly every day it was
amazing
but I can't I can't imagine having uh
trying to bring this to life and Landing
those two as your leads and everything
and then you know Jordan Peel's company
wanting to come on you know what I mean
it's like you guys won the lottery it
truly feels that way yeah I mean I think
we've lived with this story and these
characters for so long and
um it's one thing to see it come to life
but it's also another thing to see it
come to life idealistically you know
like I'm we're like we couldn't have
asked for a more perfect time yeah I
think it's one thing to see it come to
life and there's another thing to see it
have a life and have a life and that's
something I think that for sure uh um
focus and monkey paw Have Been
instrumental in in
shepherding is like making sure that
people know about this yeah I think it's
gonna be my last question but I read
that it was your actual grandmother's
hats that you used in the film is that
true and can you sort of talk about her
hat collection it's very true a lot of
the hats in the film like in the in the
closet and in the the hat store or our
grandmother's hats and um you know she
was she was a church-going God-fearing
woman and she had lady she loved her hat
she had box I think we went through
probably
uh 20 25 boxes of filled with different
hats
um and
um you know it was a she she passed away
in 2011 but it was important for us to
have a piece of her in the film
um and so that's we that was I think the
best way we knew how to do it yeah I
have to stop there I'm just gonna say
congrats on the movie I hope you guys
are making something else again soon
thank you so much we are doing that
I like that thank you have a great day
you too bye